so this first question is one of those
questions and the question was something
along the lines of this it was something
like what should I do if a peer of mine
is working hard putting an extra effort
and trying to shine so that they get
promoted that was the question and
that's a good question right cuz right
what do you do and and the instinct is
well like you know what I'm saying you
can even feel that it's tick I can see
the look on your face right now
yes you have the look on your face of
like you can see that that's a little
bit offensive right when you go oh this
person's trying to work are trying to
put that extra effort and trying to
shine so that they can get promoted
right no one likes that person by the
way right no one likes the the
brown-noser yeah so we get it so then
the question was what should this person
do what you know that's the guy asked me
what do I do when that's happening and
the instinct which is the instinct you
had which is the instinct my first
instinct even me mr. keep your ego in
check my very first instinct is like a
little bit of like a push back like oh
that guy and I want to lash out at him
right but that's not the right answer
you know cuz well that's what you say is
you say yeah look at what they're doing
so you know what that is that's making
those attacks that's your own personal
ego that's my own ego my own ego going
well that person just wants to get
promoted so if you can take a second you
can take a step back you can detach you
can put your ego in check and if you do
that then you say to yourself okay
here's what's here's the situation if we
remove the Eagle here's the situation
this person is working extra hard by the
way this person's appear so we're on the
same team this person is working extra
hard they're putting in extra effort
they are trying to shine and all those
things all those things are actually
good for your team
right I got someone that's trying to do
a great job that's working harder I'm
actually happy hmm I'm actually happy if
there's a person working harder all my
team that's good if there's a person
that's you're trying to outwork me and
do a better job than me that's actually
awesome because now we're gonna be a
better team mmm now mind you any moment
you let your ego slip into this it's it
turns into a nightmare it's not good you
don't like it you're offended that
someone's trying to work harder than you
but if you keep your ego in check then
that's good you realize that it's good
and I'll tell you something else and
this is worth what I answered this
question I said for this person to
outwork me he's gonna have a hard time
he's gonna have a hard time out working
because I'm here to win - and that is a
little bit of my ego mmm but that mean
that egos being a positive thing because
I'm oh you're gonna step up your game
guess what I'm gonna do step up my game
I'm not gonna undermine you that would
be negative that would be my you go
causing a problem but if I go oh you're
so Echo's stepping up his game
Echo's showing up it at 6 o'clock in the
morning instead of instead of 6:10 oh
and I'm and I'm coming in at 6:05 guess
what guess what I'm coming in tomorrow
no 4:30 but you're right so I do I just
do a little bit more so now
now we're both a little bit more
prepared now we got some good
competitiveness going on that's good
it's good for the team so you this other
person this other person that's stepping
up their game trying to do a good job is
actually awesome because it's gonna make
me step up my game and I'm gonna tell
you right now that person is gonna have
a hard time out working me there have a
hard time
bring it I'm actually fired up I'm
actually getting fired up right now like
I'm getting view I'm starting like I'm
thinking I might attack you right now
just to see what's up so that's good
now here's years where the second ego
scenario that you have to get under
control what if that person steps up
their game I step up my game they end up
they actually do end up
outshining me they actually do end up
getting the big promotion mmm then what
do I do
do I get better do I get jealous do I
get mad do I now start to undermine them
and spread rumors about no actually if
somebody if somebody outworked me mm-hmm
and outperformed me and then got
promoted good for them
that is awesome credit they get a credit
you're done good son you're done good
and there's nothing wrong with that and
what I am gonna do is instead of being
bitter and mad and jealous and all those
things instead I'm actually gonna put my
ego out of the picture and say what
actually happened where did this person
perform better than me and how I how can
I support them how can I learn some
lessons from this and how can I become
better so the next time there is an
opportunity I do get promoted you
wouldn't think that that question is
about your own personal ego from the
beginning now it's easy to see looking
back yeah but from the beginning it's
like hey what do you do how do you
handle this situation when someone's
trying to outwork you now shine you and
they're trying to get promoted that
sounds like an interpersonal
relationship question is not it's a
question about ego